[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the Barrister
and former government Minister Anna
subri and the director of the onward
Think Tank Sebastian Payne with us from
now until just before midnight so
welcome to both of you as ever let's
kick off with the front pages starting
with the Metro their front page focusing
on the Prime Minister ordering a probe
into former Chancellor Nadeem zahawi's
tax affairs with the headline Rish dish
the dirt
that story also making the front of the
Ft the headline reading Sahari fights
for his political life over tax Scandal
as soon as orders an Ethics review
so Howie faces the sac as the PM demands
answers that's the front as you can see
of the eye the star also leads with that
story writing you don't need a lettuce
to see how this one ends in reference to
their live streamed lettuce which
outlasted Liz truss's term as prime
minister was an iceberg there wasn't it
alternatively the express leads with the
story of triple murderer tricking his
way into Britain by posing as a child
Asylum Seeker that's through also on the
front page of the telegraph killer posed
as a child to claim Asylum and murder
again in the UK more papers coming in as
we speak we'll get to them as we can
just quick reminder though by scanning
the QR code you'll see on screen you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers well you watch us so let's go
straight to Anna subri and Sebastian
Payne uh Sebastian why don't you kick us
off zahari fights for his political life
makes the front page of a number of
newspapers and soon like ordering an
Ethics review and all of this really I
suppose dated from Boris Johnson's time
what he was rambling around losing
ministers trying to find a Chancellor
for himself remind us if you can
well the story actually goes back a
little bit further than that it's Nadeem
sahawi who is conservative party
chairman and was very briefly Chancellor
at the very end of the dying days of
boys Johnson's government uh you know he
was founder of Hugo which is the very
successful big polling company he's been
a lot of backwards and forwards about
when yougov was sold and what happened
to Mr zahawi share price and there was a
lot of discussion about when he was made
chanced about whether he was under
investigation by hmrc and we've learned
over the past week that um he obviously
was under investigation and that he has
paid a retrospective sum in terms of tax
with regards to the shares of yougov but
then has also been reports of that he
was fined by hmrc because of what he
paying the tax when you shares were sold
there so really where we've got to with
this is that Mr zahari has struggled
with the past couple of days in terms of
reports but there's now been a full
investigation into what's going on by
the PM's independent advisor on Minister
your interests and those viewers with a
longer memory will remember Lord
Christopher guide who is the foreign
minister interest advisor investigated
Boris Johnson under
um party gate wallpaper gate all the
gates you could possibly imagine his
replacement is soloi Magnus who's a
former banker and this is his first
major investigation and throughout this
we should say Mr zahari said that there
was no intentional wrongdoing and that
what happened was a mistake and the
money has been paid and he has
apologized for that ever but politically
it's obviously a bit of a tricky
position for Rishi sunak because
um this story has been building for a
couple of days now and I think it's sort
of distracting from what he wants to do
with the government that he started the
new year with his five-point plan about
how to refresh the economy at refresh
the economy refresh the party focus on
the core issues the government wants to
make progress on which is obviously
inflation interest rates all that sort
of thing but ultimately this is the kind
of sort of this this element of sleaze
now onward we've done research search
into problems with the perception of the
conservative party's brand and that
sense of sleaze of things not being
above the board is one of the biggest
risks for the party so I'm sure Mr sunac
will be hoping this will go away rather
soon but by starting the investigation
to Mr zahari it means basically he won't
be able to say any more about it and
when it comes to that crucial PM cues on
Wednesday all he'll be saying is as we
were once waiting for Sue gray we're now
waiting for Laurie Magnus absolutely yes
it feels identical doesn't it in some
respects but it does exacerbate that
impression does it not of the wealth of
some Tory members compared to struggling
workers at the moment who can't pay
their fuel bills and the I Anna says
that they've been told sunak would not
have backed the hallway publicly if he
had known the full story
um despite the Prime Minister
questioning his conduct so how he
believes he will keep his job as allies
say number 10 knows how effective he is
at cchq and how likely he is to be
cleared so she should he be suspended
while an investigation is underway do
you think because he's he's ineffective
in his role at the moment is he not
while this Cloud hangs over him
look I'm just thinking of all those fans
that were singing about Frank Lampard
sacked in the morning you're going to
get sacked in the morning and that is
what comes out to me about the zahawi
affair is that you just get this feeling
that you can't see how he's now going to
survive as Sebastian says through to
pmqs and if it's right that zunak didn't
know all the details and and I may have
got this wrong and I'm not sure did he
not know all the details when he spoke
at PM Cahoots last week or was it when
he actually appointed him in any event
if sunak thinks that zahari has not been
upfront with him then he won't hesitate
to get rid of him but at the moment you
don't feel there's a great crying out
from the conservative back benches to
SAC Nadeem zahawi a lot of that will be
because he's actually
um he's actually hugely personable and
he's liked it won't matter there's a
real as Sebastian says real reputational
damage here that real strong sniff of
sneeze and as you say Anna there's also
the fact that people say five million
pounds what repaid and in a fight God
what world do these people live in it's
not the world that I am living in uh in
the economic crisis that the country is
in yes Nadim as a whole we seem to have
done very well in his role as vaccines
Minister which was seen at the time as
utterly crucial in getting the UK you
know free from Lockdown and free from
disease to be fair at that point wasn't
it a Sebastian yeah I suppose the
question is when was this settled was it
settled when he in a rush as I hinted
became Chancellor and therefore as far
as Rishi sunak was concerned the matters
had been dealt with when he was asked
about it in pmqs last week anyway all of
this will come out uh in this inquiry we
wait for that so
um you know what happens in the interim
then in terms of reputational damage to
zahawianta sunac Sebastian
or just to Echo what Anna said I think
Nadim zahari because you know I think
Ian Duncan Smith the former toy party
leader was on the broadcast rounds this
weekend and he said uh you know that
there were some more questions to be
answered and clearly the Prime Minister
has come to that same conclusion
otherwise he wouldn't have asked sir
Laurie Magnus to investigate Nadeem
sahawi if he felt everything was
entirely clears there are some maths
that need to be cleared up and I think
the chief wad is all about the timeline
of when this happened because there's
been quite a lot of conflicting reports
and statements about what happened but I
think Anna is also right that Nadeem
zahawi is well liked among Tori MPS that
he became the MP the strapped our name
and in 2010 and he didn't do that one in
the David Cameron government but then
after brexit he was a long-term
supporter of Boris Johnson and back
brexit and then his first big role as
you said was very much the vaccines
Minister and I think we'll remember from
those Darkest Days the pandemic when he
was came in to really push people to get
jobs and was seen in Whitehall as being
very success useful in terms of getting
the vaccines rolled out so I think
that's why he's risen very quickly and
then he had that role very briefly as
Chancellor at the end of Boris Johnson's
time and then he did briefly Run for the
toy party leadership but I didn't really
get very far on that basis then
obviously under Liz truss he was um he
he you know he he's been on a bit of a
merry-go-round of ministerial Rose for
the moment but I think the government is
clearly quite low to lose him because if
the story had got to this stage when
you're a net prime minister you have a
decision do you just decide to spend the
political capital and save him or do you
cut him loose now that was the decision
where she sunac faced today and there
was an editorial on conservative home
which is a popular Grassroots website
and this is what they said that Rishi
Sula needs to decide is he going to back
or sack Nadeem zahawi he's allowing this
to drift on is the worst of all worlds
and essentially they are backing him
because if they were going to sack him
they would have done that he's made it
clear he thinks he's done nothing wrong
and he's not going to resign so what
happens now to your original question
the answer is we wait for Lorry Magnus
because he's not the Prime Minister will
now say on every question he's asked
about Nadeem zahawi I want full clarity
there's now an investigation and
whenever Mrs zahari or another
government Minister has asked they will
say the same thing it's under
investigation so for the moment really
nothing more is going to happen but the
crucial thing of course with all this is
does the media report more are there
more stories and if that builds up ahead
of steam then events could overtake that
investigation but I imagine Mr Magnus
will be under much pressure to get this
done pretty soon so there's Clarity
either way okay I just wanted to ask
Anna as we look at the Daily Star you
don't need a Daily Star lettuce to see
how this one ends we save ourselves 60p
on a leafy veg is how they put it
um you know and Anna how much does this
have oh Anna's not their apology she's
gone okay fine
um
Anna are you back
no she's not she's not back anyway I'm
going to move on if you don't mind I'm
going to save that question as an xpx
um MP but I want to move on to the uh
Daily Telegraph uh China uh threats or
fears about China it can exploit laptops
cars and even fridges to spy on the UK
tell us more about this Sebastian
so this speaks to a growing concern
amongst ministers in the state that
actually the UK has gone too far in
terms of allowing China's access to core
bits of national infrastructure in terms
of technology and in terms of um of
intellectual property within the UK and
viewers will know that you we've had
lots of ups and downs in terms of our
relationship with China under David
Cameron and George Osborne We had the
so-called Golden Era when we were very
much trying to allow trying to come in
invest in the UK and the result of that
now is China has become more more
authoritarian is they do own and have
access to sort of big parts of crucial
parts of the UK economy and the story on
the telegraph is actually saying in some
respects it's too late in terms of what
they own the amount of Technology that's
on the use across the economy and you
know ministers made that big decision
about 18 months ago with regards to
Huawei which is the Chinese tech
telecoms company and allowing them to
have a bigger role in in the UK's 5G
Network at first they were a limited
role then that was u-turned and then
they were now Allowed no role at all and
that has stored the UK's 5G rollout and
added a lot of extra expense so a lot of
push and pull here but I think the
significance this Telegraph story is
ministers want to say it's okay we've
got control of this we're keeping China
away from the critical stuff this story
in fact is kind of saying the opposite
and saying it's too late we've already
passed that Rubicon and now China really
has a problematic role in terms of our
national security that's it's very
interesting isn't it Anna you've joined
us I'm going to try and see if you can
pick up on that the idea that
um microchips have been weaponized it's
like Trojan Horse technology which poses
a wide-ranging threat to the UK and this
idea but we are we just a bit sleep I
sleep on the job in terms of Technology
hmm
well what you might be making a very
good point on that latter part but I
suspect that it's it's these sorts of
things could always have been predicted
look at the situation with China has
always been difficult because it gives
right to the heart of if you're like
modern foreign policy whereby you say
look if you reach out with trade if you
if you make connections then that is the
way to get that sort of if you like
regime change without having to go to to
war or into into conflict and that if
you as I say engage then a people will
want more democracy a regime will change
it will open up it will give its people
democracy uh and it will be the end of
the Tyranny that's existed in China for
actually many centuries and you know
there's a good event that was the theory
if you like behind it all and I'd be the
first to admit that actually there's
been no real I don't there's anything
real change in China at all you know
there have been crumbs of comfort so
when people said that they were
absolutely fed up with the code
restrictions you'll remember a few weeks
ago then the Chinese government were
almost forced to change but that's not
the same as really opening up and being
a free open Democratic Society it is a
totalitarian and it is a brutal regime
and I would as I say be the first to say
that what we were trying to achieve and
it had actually been going on for
decades before Ted Heath was one of the
first people to reach out to China and
try to to bring it into a more or
frankly more civilized and Democratic
way of behavior and conducting its
Affairs um and we've not we've not been
successful well welcome back you're
watching the Press preview joining me
once again Anna subri and Sebastian
Payne welcome back to both of you
um Anna Daily Mail an article by Boris
Johnson what the hell is the West
waiting for where he describes going to
Butcher and standing over the graves of
some of the 400 16 inhabitants of this
town nine of them children who he says
were shot by the Russians in an attempt
to terrify the rest tell us more
well first
what you can't argue with is what is
happening in the Ukraine and the need of
the West to up its game I I completely
agree with all of that I think there is
the most appalling tragedy still being
played out by the Russians their illegal
Invasion they're just appalling tactics
deliberately targeting the holy innocent
civilians including of course children
and it's just appalling and we're not
still doing enough and we know our
country's done a great deal but
collectively we've got to do a lot more
we can talk about Germany and tanks and
so on and so forth but the other
question I think is that what the hell
is Boris Johnson doing we know he went
there yesterday acting as if he was
still our prime minister and I think
he's on maneuvers I have no doubt about
that whatsoever because in May I think
that the conservatives will do very
badly in the local elections and I think
he is absolutely rolling the pitch after
those huge election defeats in May to
say look I'm the man I'm the man who
will save the conservatives from
absolute obliteration come the next
general election and and I'm sorry to be
cynical and and it shouldn't be like
this for goodness sakes because it is
appalling what's happening
but I think this is blatant maneuvering
by Boris Johnson but what he actually
says is absolutely spot on yes
maneuvering for what though I mean to be
PM again or to be Envoy to Ukraine for
the British government or that he's got
time on his hands to do this now and he
you know sees it as very important and
they're shaking her head um Sebastian
your view
let me be a little less cynical just for
a moment there even though I think I can
appreciate a lot of people appreciate
where Anna is coming from here so
earlier in his career Boris Johnson
actually wanted to be a war reporter
that after he was Brussels correspondent
for the Daily Telegraph in the late 80s
in the early 1990s he asked sir Max
Hastings who was the editor of the Delhi
teller could he go off and be a war
correspondent I think it would have been
Serbian Kosovo at that time and Max
Hastings said no you're completely also
to do this you should actually come back
and be our star political columnist and
for a lot of people that will be oh well
wonderful that that's a brilliant job
but actually Boris always likes to be
out there and be a man of action he was
quite disappointed and what I find
fascinating about this article is an
insight into a career that never
happened for Boris Johnson which was to
be a war correspondent if you read the
passion that he's written this article
in it really is exploring the graphic
detail takes you right into those
horrific scenes that he describes in the
suburbs of Kiev there
um so there's no doubt about it that you
know he is a very very good writer and
he's very passionate what he's saying I
mean there is no getting away from the
Optics of this the biggest selling
country of the paper has put its front
page with a big piece by Boris Johnson
it doesn't take a smart particular
analyst to tell you what Anna was
getting at this is very helpful for him
politically is he on maneuvers I mean
I'm just a little bit more skeptical
than some people on this just because I
think how do you become leader of the
conservative party it's through the MPS
and I I don't get a big sense that a lot
of MPS want him back at the moment that
may change after May's elections to
Anna's point but for now I think they
just want to calm things down but it's
clear that Johnson's most passionate
supporters they certainly want him back
and they'll be loving this front page